et une autre manifestation se déroule en
ce moment même à proximité du ministère
du logement pour demander la réquisition
des logements vides à paris en france
trois cent mille personnes sont sans
domicile fixe et 2,8 millions sont
considérés comme mal-logé le collectif
d'associations à l'origine de la
mobilisation demande à l'exécutif
d'appliquer la loi sur la réquisition de
4 millions de logements vides est
disponible le porte-parole de l'euro
logements étaient notamment présents
dans le cortège on est là avec les
collectifs de sans abri le dal et plein
d'autres associations et collectifs pour
demander au ministère du logement qui
est juste là demandé à madame wargon de
réquisitionner le froid arrive on est on
a eu nos prêts à risque d'augmentation
importante de la pandémie et on a trois
millions de logements vacants
donc qu'est ce qu'on fait dans ce pays
alors qu'il ya des gens qui sont dehors
qui sont dans la rue qui crève à petit
feu on a des logements qui reste vacant
par négligence ou par spéculation
c'est une honte c'est comme si on
laissait comme sûrs d'être usé d de la
nourriture devant des affamés c'est la
même chose et donc là maintenant il faut
réquisitionner
on demande à ce gouvernement d'appliquer
la loi tout simplement la loi la loi de
réquisition de gaulle l'a fait chirac a
failli en a plein qui l'ont fait avant
eux pourquoi ils l'ont fait il ne faut
pas eu